Okay.
We have a voicemail number.
That number is two one nine two David P ever
since my story earlier this week about Donald
Trump and his drawer full of Sudafed, which
coincides with what people have said, who
spent time with him on the apprentice, that
he's regularly eating Sudafed and snorting
Adderall.
A lot of voicemails like this one saying,
David, you are absolutely right and I'm glad
you're talking about this.
Okay.
Hey David, I just wanted to call and thank
you for finally starting to say what is actually
going on with Trump.
Um, he's not crazy.
Yeah.
Not unhinged.
You know, all these words that we use, it's
clear to anybody who has been in the addiction
industry or has been addicted to any sort
of amphetamine is that he's, he's high and
he's coming down or any higher and he's coming
down and then the high and he's, he's classic.
Everything had he done it is what that is.
Um, and the sad thing and the scary thing
is, and he's not going to get better.
There's only going to get worse.
So just,
yeah.
So listen, he may still be unhinged and all
of those other things, but he also may be
addicted to, uh, amphetamines.
Uh, we don't know for sure.
We may never know for sure, but so many, uh,
addiction professionals getting in touch and
saying, David,
uh, I think you're right.
I've been observing this for a while and I
think you're absolutely spot on.
We've got a great bonus show planned for you
today.
Become a member or a patron to get instant
[inaudible] the David Pakman show@davidpakman.com
[inaudible].